am i still winning i don't know i am i
am i'm still winning okay great
i'm still winning
we are good ladies and gentlemen
this is how you win a game
let's go
[Music]
hello everyone
and welcome title tuesday time
is playing everybody's playing
gonna be a grind but we'll try to keep
the positive title tuesday streak going
last three
title tuesdays have gone really well so
grishok is playing okay so let's
literally oh grisha gekko suga's playing
this is going to be this is one of the
strongest title tuesdays i've ever seen
every single person's playing
okay we're playing
some guy
jorge bobadia
all right all right boba dear let's go
okay let's play check
castles
okay rookie one
g6 everybody plays this
okay that's actually the best line
i think the move is a4 that i looked at
now black's supposed to take twice but
not a lot of people know that queen c7
okay so this is just slightly better for
white i could take on e5 but i don't
love that
play bishop g5
yeah bishop g5 is interesting
complete d5
yeah let's go d5 let's go with the right
lopez structure
let's go to e3
knight f6 okay could go g3
yeah i like the idea of going g3 and
knight h4
we're limiting this knight
not enthralled in my position here
okay he's gonna go b5 i'm not sure what
my plan should be here
this bishop d7
maybe b4
yeah i already don't like the way i'm
playing
just go like this
let's go c4
probably should have put a knight there
instead yeah definitely should have put
a knight there instead
nh7
let's go bishop d1
whoa
did not see that move
okay i'm getting soundly outplayed here
and four wow
takes takes knight g2 maybe
okay let's let's try it
yeah actually this might be the way to
go
if queen e5 i have bishop c3
and i t okay now i i think i'm getting a
little edge here and i'm gonna start
pushing my center pawns
rookie three maybe
or is that too slow maybe i should have
gone f4
i also have b3 in my pocket okay never
mind
let's go up four
okay i think i should throw in the p3
just because it opens up the queen that
i don't think that can hurt
okay that's annoying but i guess e5
is it time 35 maybe i should throw in
bishop c2 one more move and then e5
yeah i was worried he would move his
king
should have just gone e5 straight away
of course
knight h4 he has g5
let's go h4
okay now definitely five
um queen f6 said i have bishop g6 for
starters
yeah in fact that's what i should do
rookie five i think i go queen e5
it goes right there but now i can take
now
oh it takes takes there there no that's
winning
if he takes i win
yeah i saw that move okay now there's no
way this wait does this work
whoa it takes a perpetual
jesus oh i have king g3 oh my god i have
this move
oh that's so lucky if i took it i think
it's just perpetual queen of three no
but now i take and it's over
jesus
okay cafe let's just be very very
careful here rook f5 force the queen
trade game is over
take the queen and now actually check in
with the second rook
okay tough game
okay
let's go king's indian
oh
there's a tory attack that's even more
annoying to london
okay it's a knight t5
this is theory
but that's all i know
okay cd he takes e7
i guess that's bad
one is in trouble
rookie eight maybe it
it's a little bit iffy because my pawn
on f7 is going to be weak but i think i
can get away with it
wait wait wait wait wait wait it's a
trap you want to take and go knight g5
and beat me
okay so therefore i go h6
that's a devilish move of bishop h4
he was threatening to take and gun i
almost blundered that knight g5
okay queenie force now he wants to take
care of god this guy won't let me
breathe
wait 961 is the queen
cd queen g6 is bad am i just in trouble
here
we're strange position
there's no way i've got to have a move
here there's no way this just like wins
for white or something
when c7 he's got bishop g3 then queen c6
maybe
it's definitely bad
okay my idea is queen g6 i have c4
now but now d5 i'm i'm getting okay
takes it that's that's actually kind of
a relief
i'm worse in the end game but this is
playable i mean i can i can outplay him
here i think
okay what's this bullet writing is 2600
bullet okay so we need to get him to
time pressure
okay i could take and go bishop b7 maybe
and now i'm threatening c5
okay my pawns are crappy but
maybe knight c5
bishop c2 i'm not sure what i'm going to
do he gives me the bishop
okay actually let's let's bring the rook
into the
game goes bishop c2 actually i should
have i should have definitely taken that
bishop
bone had a decision by me
knight a4
is interesting but no it doesn't work he
takes
another fantastic move by him
you're getting utterly outplayed here
oh i can't even go knight okay i'm just
flat out in huge trouble here
be four is nasty
okay let's go c5 at least open up some
pieces
i i don't think i'm like losing but
like i'm not not in control of this game
at all
knight e3 rook t7
i guess i go rook c7 to stop rook d7
he has a check on d5 then i take it we
get an end game
but then i go 93 in the end so
okay i don't want to take the bishop if
i take the bishop i'm in trouble let's
go e5
let's try to get a passer
okay i actually quit taking go king
e6 yeah maybe it's the way to go
take take e6
no but i'm just worse than that position
let's go back
just try to keep some imbalance
oh
um but this is just bad
i'm gonna offer a draw
he takes it
yeah i'm just worse here i have no
winning chances i mean white is just
much better
just played well i mean i don't know
would say just he played better than me
um
he just simply played better than me
but i was better here i could have gone
e5
misplayed this this segment of the game
okay it's not a terrible result at least
i'm gonna get some easier pairings for a
couple rounds
okay let's go
let's go e4
anyways we'll talk about it later
let's play the junatus french
i can play c3 actually here but the move
is here
this is all theory
this is all i know now i'm out of book
white's supposed to be a smidge
smidge better
smidge nasal
i don't love my position
okay but g5 i think is weakening
maybe i can throw an h3
okay let's just throw in this move just
for some left
king f8
crap i don't have any tactics on the
king's side
god he really knows what he's doing here
doesn't he
okay please go king g7
oh oh this is sexy check
this wins on the spot
oh yes
wins a piece
oh man
okay now let's let's not uh let's not
screw this up
oh my god that was sexy
i had a game
in the u.s championship against holt or
i missed this exact idea so that's how i
knew about it
okay how do we win this
quickly i could go h4
could go rookie on he's gonna go f60 i
need to find a way to stop f65
okay i think i know how to do it i think
i go here
in order to be able to play f4
and then f5 is a huge threat
because b4
okay i could take could take first and
then take
you saw it that's annoying
okay
actually not as easy to win a position
like this as it appears
knight c6 this has to be completely
crushing
yeah luft is a standard i open the chat
again by the way luft is a standard term
i'm pretty sure it's not left lock
it's it's just lift okay wait
this guy's defending super resiliently
and i just realized i only have like one
pawn
left okay rook b5 i think is simple
okay this is over
oh bishop g3 was so much better ah
i should g3 one on the spot i don't know
why i'm playing like
like this
i'm i'm gonna win this but
it's gonna take forever
come on that was just that was a dumb
dumb moment
um g4 check and g3 what's the
simplest
okay just resigns all right cool
okay groceries one god everybody's
everybody's on three out of three
eric wins okay so everybody is on three
out of three
except me
wesley's also playing
okay oparin has two and a half gotta has
two and a half i'm gonna play somebody
really strong right now because
there's a lot of really good people two
and a half
women's grandmaster senura oh this is
also okay
she's good
what do we play i guess we play e5
hmm i was always afraid of this move but
i know it's not supposed to be good
okay i think i take
wait up this this this is not it's not
right
so i could take on e5 ricky five king up
eight
or like a castle
[Music]
this is my game against fabi so he takes
d4 is the move
yeah she forgot that i could castle i
think
she also has three out of three so
we need to win this game
yeah cd4
i think i play knight takes d4
okay she plays bishop c6 so dc
[Music]
well dc doesn't look right
i could play bc but i should probably
play bishop c6
okay i'm up a pawn i've got a nice
position here but my structure's ruined
could take the queen and go knight d5
that looks very that end game looks very
appealing
but i feel like she'll go knight d4
i what are the alternatives i could go
queen h4
park my queen on h4
she'll go h3 i'll go knight d5
maybe knight a5 and i have bishop d4
yeah that looks right
i think this is right
queen f3 which i didn't
look at for whatever reason
okay i think we go
here
and then rookie eight quickly
the the good thing is that white can't
really move the bishop out because the
bishop takes b2
was g3
could swing my queen to a bunch of
different places queen h3 is even
possible mcqueen h3 queen d7
i don't really want to go passive though
queen a4 maybe but then rookie four
i don't really know what to do i'll go
queen h3 i want to keep a time advantage
knight a5 i'll go back to d7 i think
or maybe at night a5 i go rook a8
okay
so i could take here
rook ab1
back then she takes
i don't want to give up that somehow i
want to keep this pawn this pawn anchors
my knight
okay we're getting her low on time
which is good
okay okay d1 that's an annoying move
but what if i take i don't see should
page six maybe
could also take on
e1 first which takes the bishop should
be two
let's take it let's see what she takes
oh it with be two queenie two what am i
doing
ship c3
it's a really good move
that's a really really good move i
didn't see any of that
i might not be able to win this
i hope she takes here that loses
yeah i'm gonna win
yeah good
yeah because gh queen g4 check
king has to move to the first rank i
take the rook with check and i win
thank you ali and then if the king moves
back
then it's made in two well here made in
two queen e2 and queen takes d1 if the
king moves back here check on e1
and then mate back ranked mate
easy tactic
yeah this was nice
it's actually the top move according to
the engine knight f5
so it wasn't just a cheap trick
okay so of course the car will won
easily
um let's see
alexander lenderman is four out of four
two
okay oh we're playing lenderman yeah
that's a nasty little pairing
what do we play let's go e4
i know he likes the french and stuff
yeah he's literally berserking i mean
he's half his time left
there we go all right
let's think
we got to play something
of the rare variety maybe
let's play a fantasy let's play
something tactical
my d7 i don't know
okay e5
go here
yeah bishop c5 is annoying here though
um
shift c4 maybe not sure
um i thought i have e5 here but i don't
rook a d1 maybe should be better in the
end game
now b5 is very annoying oh no b5 doesn't
really work i go bishop b3
b5 there should be 3 c5
rook d6
rook d1 c4 knight takes b5 cb knight c7
king d8
you know it's got to be good for me
must be good for me
okay does go for it
i could also go knight takes b5 but then
he traps my knight at the end of the
line that i saw
okay let's figure out where to go with
the rook
okay it's got to be d2 or d1 d1 then
you see then you can see v at the end
hmm
every rook move is a downside and i'm
not sure
which one is better
okay i'm gonna go rugby too
because i this gives me the potential to
double also
or did i blonder bishop a6 or something
didn't really consider alternative now
he goes for c4
oh bishop a6 this i missed completely
this one i missed
completely i forgot he has king e7
don't love this
now knight d5 issue basics really
unfortunate
wait knight v5 careful let's go
i should go for it i can't make a draw
here
and i should have of course
oh crap
crap
ah i'm gonna lose
blunder that
oh my god moved daniel
let's see how to win this
oh i had rook i had a win oh no i had a
win in the spot
i could have won
that's sag
but okay i was in time pressure
this is a draw now
yeah i just forgot
i had a move there
oh
i'm holding a flag
okay last attempt here go around
okay draw
yeah i had one chance there to skewer
him actually
crap i had one chance there
ugh rg8 it's over
very very bad
missed the chance
yeah i can't i can't draw a game like
that i mean he spotted me 90 seconds but
he was fast and very strong
okay wait g4 here
this i don't know about because knight
h4 i've got takes
okay d5 is interesting
i guess i go here
now i'm worse
get that castle
hopefully we can get him low on time
i'm definitely worse with this at least
my king is okay
now he goes
there's the most annoying possible moves
knight d7 maybe
queen okay i don't really need to play
knight d7
no but
it's such a hard position to play i
guess i'll go here
okay thanks
okay this pawn is hanging also a problem
queen c6 maybe queen b5 is interesting
situation
h4 at some point
how am i going to win this
okay i'm gonna take a risk i'm gonna go
h4
somehow i need to unbalance the position
obviously h4 is bad objectively but
the way he's been playing i'm sure he'll
feeling he'll punish me my idea was to
swing the queen around to h5
he's also kind of low on time
yeah this is nothing
okay we take
oh wait this this looks very flimsy
though
i didn't think this was good
maybe knight g5 knight f3
i don't know this feels right let's just
go i need to keep myself some time
g3 is a sort of a threat
okay he parries it or eight first or
should we go knight f3 immediately
hard to
say very hard to say i'm going to go
rook f8 first
rook f2 is obviously a big threat
okay where's the mate it's got to be a
mate here e5 maybe
oh he just takes it
oh crap i forgot about that completely
oh yeah yay
how bad is this let's see
queen g5 maybe
and quickly bishop c1
i don't know it's very very hard to say
ng56
i
yes got him got him got him got him got
him the trick at the end
oh my god i came so close to losing on
time so many times
oh my god holy smokes
got him with that dirty trick in the end
okay great let's go e4
okay another check
let's go c4
there's e6 okay that's fine
okay just going to castle that's fine
with me
takes a b3 slightly better for white
i think
yeah i like these kinds of positions in
general
okay here we'll go queen e2 or where
rook c1 makes sense
okay let's go over to c1 for now see how
he positions his pieces
okay queen c7 let's go rook e1
rook d8
knight d5 is always tempting in these
types of positions but i think it's
premature
okay let's get our queen maybe to h3
that feels right maybe some sax on e6
something to that effect
this bishop f8
which i honestly forgot about
okay let's go here
it's gonna go g6 probably
yeah i'm not too impressed with my play
here does go g6
okay let's go rook cd one because if you
fancy i feel like i can maybe target
this pawn
i don't know how yet but we'll figure
that out i guess
no maybe not
oh he's just got a nice he's outplayed
me actually
sort of
let's go h3 let's make some left
knight c5
hmm okay let's
just let's centralize
maybe we can double rooks
on the d file eventually maybe we can
attack the d6 one
you cannot allow b5 that's the one thing
very careful about
he does go you go b5 anyway
what did i blunder
okay well i kind of
wait i can take and go before
hmm
complex stakes takes oh he wants 94
that's what i missed
okay and the resulting position is going
to be
unclear
okay it all starts with taking so e5
he has maybe b4
e5 t takes i take it takes a take
goes there he has knight d3 on the end
a2903
d1 not good
let's go b4
not sure that this is best
okay maybe b5 i wanted to go a3
yeah b5 maybe the pawn is weak oh let's
go a3 let's play more solidly
i'm just gonna go knight this is
no bueno
is this move
okay solid solid that may be g3
let's look at him in my knight
it's h5
it's a really good move jesus
okay hopefully he misses some sort of
knight takes e6 trick
okay no he doesn't i didn't see this
move at all
rook c3
i can push then no
god this guy is crazy good
i have a feeling where this game is
going to go
into the toilet
i don't have moves
okay at least i got my rook to the first
drink oh he goes rick c1
um
i'm just winning here
yes got him tricked him in the end
another
gritty win
who are we playing we're playing hicaro
with white okay okay god great
okay if he plays the relentless take him
into a draw
not in the mood
i'm not in the mood guys i'm not a mute
fernie
for uh
um
what's going to
emerge i could play bishop a4
um but he knows that line pretty well
i'm gonna take the drone i'm not in the
mood right now
all right at least we'll get a little
rest
i'll try to win the rest of the games
and get nine and a half out of out of
11.
yeah gg i invented this line actually
has anyone ever tried something else in
this berlin yeah there's other i used to
play this line
full time but i wouldn't take the draw i
would play
i would play take stakes in queen d3
this is a lion also this is interesting
but there's this move queen d7 that just
takes this line out completely if i
wanted to play i would have played
bishop a4 the problem is cecaro has
studied this line and it's very very
hard to generate winning chances if
black knows exactly what to do there
and if hikar doesn't want to lose with
black
i mean he's he's a hard guy to just
bring down on demand
okay we're playing wesley
yeah i get punished for making the drill
okay
uh
okay i think i can go g4
it's actually exactly like my previous
game
or the game before the game i can see
caro
but here i'm going to play better
there's f4
okay so i can take
let's take a queen of simon i'm gonna go
a long castle here
yeah maybe h5 was a mistake i need to
look at this line more carefully
okay i need to like free up the night
okay that was a bad move as well
not feeling it
okay i actually kind of like my position
now
could take on e4
could take on e4 but he gets knight d5
it says they do
i don't know this feels right
now i kind of want to play oh maybe king
b was better
before
it's going to be hard for me to generate
attacking chances here
i don't know how much time toys cause
he's about to mate me i have like a
couple moves
bishop f496 knight g5 is interesting
i actually kind of like that idea
it's weird but i think it might work out
because rook f5 i must have something
okay i can repeat i can take h3 no i
can't use queen f1
okay i cannot make a draw here no we
have to try this i literally i can make
a draw here he's gonna go for it but
i have to try this even if it fails
knight f3
what's happening here
that's a really good movie just made
okay i'm gonna go for it
has to be a win here but
we got him let's go
oh that was good
oh that was good
that was a vintage naredinsky win right
there
destroyed
let's go
ah it was satisfying
the car won again
ah that was a big deal with black
against wesley let's go
i was much worse out of the opening too
we're playing rasulullah he's beating me
and we've beaten each other a million
times before in title two stays okay
this is a winnable game we got to win
this one
hmm
it's good d6
okay because p3 which i don't know
yeah he's just playing a non-theoretical
line here
okay i could play e4
i don't trust what he's doing here
what if i go e4
let's try it let's just go for it
nothing to lose
oh we're double blacked too by the way
okay so the night will hang if i move my
night
oh okay no he can't say good i blundered
that but
you can't take the pawn
bishop a3 i've queen e5 i'm not too
scared about that
okay wait i need
my head is fog right now
let's go here
okay not h5 yeah
okay regard fader 4 maybe
is the idea
okay so now i have a nice position here
okay i'm not worried about b4
i do want to play f4 he goes queen d2 he
stops it
right no no that's a blunder that's a
blunder
let's try this move
okay i thought i'd queen before
but he just moves his knight i guess
that's fine for him
f7 is also interesting
then he goes bishop h6 i don't really
want that
okay i still allowed bishop h6
i'm a little worried about queen d6
which i didn't see i guess i've taken
over f7 it's not the end of the world
okay knight e3 has got bishop e3
okay let's just get my rook into the
game
okay oh he still has 26 i forgot about
that
i don't have to take though i can play
queen a7 or queen b6 even is interesting
and he has bishop e7 now
going before note okay we have to take
should be three is very annoying
ooh
don't i trap his bishop somehow
no i guess i don't
trip c8 is very interesting
okay i think i'm better but it's gonna
be very hard to win this
i should try go here
try to squeeze this out
g4 maybe no
um
good news
yeah this is hard to win my bishop's
locked
oh [ __ ] oh okay
oh crap why did i do that oh no
oh no this is bad
no i blundered
am i still winning i don't know i am i
am i'm still winning okay great
i'm still winning
we are good ladies and gentlemen
this is how you win a game
let's go
the car is going to win he's going to
win title tuesday we're playing for
second okay cars car is going to win oh
we're playing poravian okay
okay we're not playing boarding for
robin's good but he's beatable
okay he's going to play petrov
let me think how do i want to do this
okay let's take and go
let's go the i want to play the bishop
d3 and i forget how it goes though
how does the bishop d3 line go
crap how does it go
forgot completely
i think bishop d3 now
yeah we should d3 now
what is he thinking about
yeah it's this line
which i don't know i don't know why i
went for it
just that this is a very sharp line so
i'm going to go for it
which okay i like my position here
h3
okay c4 breakthrough i think i'm
slightly better here symmetrical pawn
structure
okay let's go c3 it's gonna be tough to
win though
let's go c3
he goes queen f6 scrap which i forgot
about
yeah this is very unpleasant actually
all of a sudden
[ __ ]
shoot
hey
why is this suddenly very unpleasant
oh yeah yeah
it's a disaster out of the opening
i shouldn't have allowed i should never
have allowed queen f6
i'm offering a draw
now i'm on my back foot okay 94
we can hold this
crap
i need to play the psychology and get
him to overpress here
okay this is a reasonable position
let me see if i'm offering a trade
i guess i take and go to step four [ __ ]
how am i gonna win this though
i mean how am i even going to draw this
okay i have to take let's think
b4 bishop b6 a4 he takes it
maybe
h4 opening f1 goes g5
king f1 he goes g5 so i guess i go here
let's not lose this
i don't know what to do here c4 is
interesting
i don't know what to do
e4 take stinks
6 8 3 g4
no let's go b3
i think i'm losing
oh it goes there it's weird
63
hmm
yeah am i not winning here
wait wait
am i not winning here
let's go
three of three
ah
let's go i got him to overpress
oh my god
only car won again you got 10 out of 11.
okay we got to congratulate him
ikaru beats boardnik in the end oh my
god
to be fair if icaru had drawn you would
have also won you got better tie breaks
than me oh
oh my god but that's so satisfying oh my
god that is honestly
one of the best finales i've ever had
probably the best clear second
gotta tip our hat to hikaro 10 out of
11. i found the one title tuesday where
nine and a half doesn't win
i know it's crazy i played like that i
beat wesley
rasulov and paravian in a row and i
can't get first oh my god i am so happy
that i managed to finish the turn i
thought i was already lost
but i realized this trick existed
i realized this trick existed
when i had c4
so here i had c4 check but it doesn't
work like this idea try to put him in
zook song thank you kavita this is
amazing but here he puts me in zoo zone
and i have to move my king back so i
noticed this trick and then i had the
same trick on the other side also didn't
work
but yeah takes in king e4 i've seen this
idea before all of a sudden he's in
zugsvang i i shoulder him out
i shoulder him out
all right guys i'm off for now i'll see
you later tonight thanks for the subs
thank you so much for the support thanks
for hanging out
later
[Music]